olive branch
wow
oliver branch and oliver branch i love
can i say one last thing or two no i
don't think so i'm going to
um in the 1950s
um during the days of the circus
barnum and bailey
they had people that performed in those
circumstances called pinheads
right can you look that up
and i just realized what oliver stopped
tree is stop he's a [ __ ] pinhead from
those old bros literally literally
that's what you wanted to say the whole
time
that's
what that call that's called what it's
called microcephaly or an encephaly
that's what he has
and that and now i have now i have
sympathy i have sympathy for you
zika virus you got a zika virus or
something just real quick pull up a
picture of humpty dumpty
gilbert you're like your job is on the
line please please please do this you
told me to respect the guests when
they're on here though all right do
humpty dumpty then let's see
the one in the blue on the right no no
[Laughter]
no no
the one right there yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah look at your little hat with the
holes in there george you're laughing a
little too loud can you put the hat back
on all right yeah i will i'll put the
bathroom
yeah click on that picture i'd like to
see that blown up yeah yeah
yeah what would that with the profile
one over there no that's the one this is
the way yeah that looks just like you
it's uncanny the result
is i'm literally we're both freaks
yeah of course yeah of course i am a
freak for sure yeah me too man there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with it the truth i think that's
the message of this
podcast today i'd say the fact is yeah
why the [ __ ] would you want to be normal
i mean who really is people that just
want to blend in i'm really good the
life that i live
i stand out
i am a freak
yeah i [ __ ] love it and people
embrace that you know people
would way rather talk to a guy who looks
like me than a guy who looks like
exactly um no but i'm another racist
thing but uh yeah but don't walk don't
walk i'm about to walk don't walk dude
you know also he reminds me of like a
combination of all the things that i've
said right there's a little kid rock in
there too i do get that a lot yeah
there's a little kid rock in there too
yeah not none of those how many kid rock
shows i've been to how many i've been to
three kid rock shows can you believe
that yeah two in vegas and one think i
don't know why you would either so you
like kidrock i used to love when i first
came to america when i first came to
america in 1998 i was 15 and my mom from
penny lane bought me two what she
thought was like the most american
albums which was um olympus kid album
and a kid rock album even though i asked
for a rage against the machine one she
didn't give me that she was like here's
this guy and he she gave me kid rock and
i was obsessed with it so it reminds me
of just did you find him attractive i
used to find him i'm trying to get out
of this podcast man
yeah i do get told that i'm doing a lot
like him for you to go to a k on a kid
rock rant right now
yeah it is insane i'm trying to get the
[ __ ] out of this thing
i mean i'll say this i don't believe in
many of the things he stands for yeah um
but i would say we do share
a very similar look and i'd say i look a
lot more like him than
the distinguished turtle or whatever
that other thing was distinguished
it's way better it's way better
distinguished yeah i mean you're a
distinguished i would say
i would say